oh bro Hobson was an animal bro yeah
it's interesting not a lot of rappers
I've used some of his bars before really
hell yeah
uh even even bigger like I remember I
wanted to sound just like bigger when I
was bro I gotta understand this because
I grew up in New York a huge big elf fan
I did not know another person outside
New York that knew who Big L was bro you
know who put me on how the [__] are you
24 years old this [__] didn't
even have papers him and his family
didn't even have papers and I'm in the
eighth grade with them and uh he was
like Hey you ever heard of big girl I
was like no who's that fool hey just put
some headphones in my ear and I think it
was like the 98 freestyle that he did
yeah and ever since then I just been in
a loophole with him bro L was so put it
on put it on with myself put it on was
great what's that there's that great
line uh the bad hoes ass beavers I got
nothing but that's the luck bro he was
one of those as a young dude who I I
cared about like you know Comedians and
being funny Etc and I saw this rapper
who was like he had crazy hard bars but
it was like really clever he had like
punch lines built into something like
that yeah it's the city cops yeah yeah
he was an animal bro definitely you ever
heard the Devil son or the devil's
advocator what is it I think it's a
devil son he says he's the son of the
devil yeah son of the devil I mean I
there's Confessions of a dice game which
is great storytelling casualties or
casualties of the dice game you know I
like I think the first person that ever
[__] me up with storytelling was Nas
because he had that rewind
he was like I think who was it who he
said it was way better was it biggie
that he said was way better storytelling
than us
biggie ghost face yeah he said somebody
nah Scarface is right but like the
rewind story from nas one telling a
story is already hard two rhyming it is
hard three rhyming it backwards right
crazy
crazy that's a whole different animal so
you would listen to a lot of East Coast
[__] you gotta understand I'd ride
around and call my mom and dad while
they doing what they doing I'm soaking
all that game up my dad Jam the Eagles
raise them against machine raise against
machine you know [__] uh Metallica uh
21 Grand [__] uh what is that
that was that 21 Guns I said uh Green
Day Green Day uh the offsprings of
course yeah I'm saying all this what
about some Chente bro um Santana just
there's no what about Vicente bro
nothing uh
no rancheras no nothing really oh and my
purple cheek was here but like I uh I
was only with him from like when I was
in Bay City because I'd be at the ranch
with him and my cousin Adrian and
Michael my cousin Michael is cold with
that web Adrian when she won couch [__]
and petrifieds and we would get Kyle
[__] and throw it in the air and Michael
oh wait with a literal whip yeah whip it
in the air that's how accurate he was a
bad [__] what the hell and he
was raining [__] who was that my cousin
Michael RP to my cowboy yeah he died on
my 10th birthday man uh that [__] was
wild
not my cowboy and he just worked on the
ranch with my pitbull Chico oh that's
cool
he died at 99 he won a plaque from the
whole southern Texas he got a black
cowboy of the century really hell yeah
that was bad [__] hit Cowboys
when I'm doing this rap [__] I want a
cowboy I saw you on the horse I was like
oh he can ride yeah yeah and what does
that mean to Cowboy like uh you have
your you have your own your your own
cattle you have your own garden and
things like that your stock you know
what I'm saying uh and and it's more
than that you know like cows you're
gonna have to [__] trim their nails
what's this trim nothing else you know
obey these [__] it's funny like
in New York we don't understand what the
job of cowboy is so we think it's just
someone who rides a horse yeah and I was
watching that yeah it was a Yellowstone
I was watching that show and I was like
oh cowboy in is the man yeah cowboy and
is it's a whole lifestyle it's a
mentality bruh yes like it's like
construction yeah for New York we have
construction and in Montana they have
Cowboy so what you just have to watch
over the horse you you're moving cattle
to different pastures repairing the
fence
they're [__] the what is it those uh
that's another thing I've been on a
weird rabbit hole and [__] Tick Tock
cleaning out the horses hooves and yeah
cutting the horses
and [__] that [__] is crazy yeah it
looks like they're cutting their foot
yeah but it's just it's just uh they
don't feel bad at all it's all new it's
all what is your nail made out of
calcium right yeah carotene bro that's
all there you go
about the calcium on my heart that's
awesome tequila is the only thing I take
care of it I got calcium on my heart
these little Young Bucks stop it bro
they think that yeah
okay I got a question about the Cowboys
you make it look good baby thank you
brother appreciate you that's why I was
so simple like I was stoked about the
Big L thing man it's because I don't
know I've just been such a big fan and
there was a couple songs that went big I
remember like even I don't you're
probably too young for this but there's
there's a phonics is how I found out
about it ebonics was great like 106 and
Park was playing Put it on yeah but my
biggest yeah yeah so it's like I was
like okay there's there's gonna be some
recognition Etc and then it kind of
moved on but I really think that he was
one of the most profound rappers for his
time like especially multi-syllabic
words like I think I think uh zero was
different definitely ahead of his time
too who zero Houston guy right who's
zero I don't know
I think he he was like I remember he was
a person that really started singing
with rap
uh there's that light skin that I'm with
the that mixed breed [__] we
kicked him out for that reason thank you
yeah
yeah no anyway beat on uh
listen bro for real yeah now he cool as
[__] though shout out my boy man like
he's definitely him and there's another
one G look those are two some bad
[__]
two of the good ones yeah
GMB GMB that's their name anyways
they're the coolest [__] not only are
they great at what they do like they're
uh
they're they're highly respected just on
face card you know what I'm saying so
like there's a lot that they can do and
uh beetles really blessed me a lot man
and uh he's the one that actually got
Paul on the song really yeah bro beat on
he's a part one of the pioneers of what
the sound of Texas is today you know
what I'm saying like what does he do he
makes bees oh he's uh yeah okay yeah
yeah and um
like g-luck his sister is a toilet uh
you know beat on he he he was already
punched in with them G and B they were
on tour with Slim Thug when they were
like 17 you know what I'm saying they've
been in the game for a minute right so
they've seen a lot too and learned a lot
they got a lot of soak up a lot of game
and [__] uh anyways back to zero he was
ahead of his time too I feel like he was
singing and had some crazy word play he
was fast as [__] he was good at telling
stories you know he was definitely an
animal for so who do you I'm trying to
think like
who do you collab with and it can be
outside of of just have I have one
because I there's some this you guys
look completely different so it sounds
weird but in your personality and you're
just who you are as an artist you remind
me of jelly roll who's a friend do you
know jelly yeah I don't know him
personally but I don't know
somebody say oh my God yeah
you guys will go he could rap too yeah
yeah he comes that's what he started us
yeah and then but that's an interesting
one because if you get both very
authentic Alex
yeah he was on that Worldwide Choppers
remember that bro remember that [__]
that skateboard video he had back in the
day was like one of the first music
videos and I think it was a remix
remember Hobson was talking [__] about
everybody that was scared he was I'm a
real estate he was talking [__] about
Lupe Fiasco yeah yeah he had a diss
track yeah Novi Novak I think too like
he was like dizzy to everyone uh The Ill
Mind of Hopsin four when he was talking
[__] on that one yeah yeah okay so who's
like a dream collab
musically somebody who just like
musically Kodak Black interesting it
could be wrong really so here's it
that's the other thing that's not my
favorite he's not my dream feature no
but here's another thing it's like
when I talked about musicality
with you and I'm like wow this guy's
really musical that's the same thing
that I say about Kodak it's fluency it's
like there's something about it that he
understands music in a way where
everything else is secondary I want to
sing with uh Stevie Ray Vaughan oh wow I
mean Rip but like the greatest guitarist
ever arguably yeah I want to sing with
him though I mean that would be so cool